-Performing her new single,
"Boys Don't Cry,"
once again, Anitta!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ "Boys Don't Cry" plays ]
♪♪
-♪ Sometimes I call you
when I can't sleep alone ♪
♪ Now you keep asking me
what that means, oh, no ♪
♪ In your feelings,
I can feel it ♪
♪ You're in your feelings ♪
♪ You won't admit it ♪
♪ But that's why
I push you away from me ♪
♪ 'Cause I know, I know ♪
♪ It drives you crazy,
try to tame me ♪
♪ But nobody's taking
control over me ♪
♪ Ooh, baby, baby,
you be talkin' tough ♪
♪ But your boys
can't get enough ♪
♪ When the girls
don't need your love ♪
♪ Who says boys don't cry? ♪
♪ Ooh, baby, baby,
you're just outta touch ♪
♪ 'Cause your boys
can't get enough ♪
♪ When the girls
don't need your love ♪
♪ Who says boys don't cry? ♪
♪ Sometimes you call me
when you're too drunk ♪
♪ Oh, God ♪
♪ Then, you start tellin' me
I'm the one, I'm not ♪
♪ In your feelings,
I can feel it ♪
♪ You're in your feelings,
you won't admit it ♪
♪ But I thought that we were
just havin' fun ♪
♪ 'Cause I know, I know ♪
♪ It drives you crazy,
try to tame me ♪
♪ But nobody's taking
control all over me ♪
♪ Ooh, baby, baby,
you been talkin' tough ♪
♪ But your boys
can't get enough ♪
♪ When the girls
don't need your love ♪
♪ Who says boys don't cry? ♪
♪ Ooh, baby, baby,
you're just outta touch ♪
♪ 'Cause your boys
can't get enough ♪
♪ When the girls
don't need your love ♪
♪ Who says boys don't cry ♪
♪ Who says they don't cry? ♪
♪ Who says boys don't cry? ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Anitta!
"Boys Don't Cry" is out now!
-♪ Hey-hey-hey hey ♪
♪♪
♪ Hey-hey-hey hey ♪